[Music]
all righty thanks a lot okay out
I warned you one drip in you're out
obviously it's Monsanto received his
third Oscar nomination for his role as a
motel manager in the florida project
with more than a hundred credits to his
name the actor is known for his
versatility he's portrayed listen to
this a soldier in platoon the Green
Goblin and spider-man and a hitman in
the grand budapest hotel got a lot of
range Willem Dafoe now he plays Vincent
van Gogh in his final years in the new
movie at eternities gate I thought an
artist had to teach how to look at the
world but I don't think that anymore now
I just think about my relationship to
Eternity what do you call the Eternity
time to come sometimes they say I'm mad
but the grain of madness is the best of
art think about that line for a second
at attorneys gate is distributed by CBS
Films that's a division of CBS and
Willem Dafoe joins us at the table it's
always good to have you here this is
what Rolling Stone says your performance
as a career best performance Julian
Schnabel said he can't imagine anybody
playing this role but you so Bravo to
you Thanks
what's about saying about this it's not
so much about the painter it is in some
part but it really focuses will on the
painting it is about painting and it was
important for me to paint in the movie
and that really became the key to
unlocking relationship to Van Gogh so
much so that you actually took lessons
didn't julienne say you're not holding
the brush right yes no it was it was
important because there's a lot of
painting in the movie and we didn't have
a stunt painter so I and we did some
long takes and some I do some painting
in real time
movie but it was important mostly - he
taught me many things about painting how
to make marks how to paint light it
really changed how I see and that was
essential and that's really the heart of
the movie because if you can kind of get
into how to look at Van Gogh's work you
can get in his head and that's the
experience in the movie I think explain
what it means seeing like a painter what
do I look like to you as a painter ah
well looking at you right now
initially I would have tried to paint a
man there but right now I'm looking at
you I'd see that white highlight here
I'd paint the light I'd paint the light
I remember trying to paint the cypress
tree and Julian was wait wait wait what
do you see see those dark spots paint
those dark spots what it does is it it's
not just deconstruction it starts to you
start to see the origin of things the
rise and fall of things and it really
opens everything's up and it's a new way
of seeing and really for me when you
start to see that happen in the movie
and you do as you watch him paint I
think it opens you up to some of the
things that he writes about in his
letters and some of yeah you really try
and deconstruct Van Gogh's life here a
part of his life you know we know that
he died at 37 what did you learn about
Van Gogh that you didn't know well I
think that he was deeply steeped in
spiritual impulse that he was much more
joyous than we often think I mean he was
ecstatic and very productive in his last
days he's considered a tortured artist
and you're focusing on his final years
when he had all those psychotic episodes
when he did some of his best work
yes but exactly he was very productive
and he was it appears from his demise vo
it appears that he was happiest when he
was painting and he was very productive
then he was basically making a painting
a day this I didn't think so much about
the tortured aspect I really
concentrated on the painting he was
tortured in the respect that it was hard
to reconcile those ecstatic states with
everyday life
and yeah you said Julian was skeptical
initially about making this film well
that's what he told me it took him a
little time as someone wanted him to
make this film and he thought why make a
film there's been so many films about
Van Gogh but he being a painter of
course has been considering Van Gogh for
all his life so yes a special
relationship and it was a it's one of
the special things about this movie is
it's a painters view of the painter yeah
it's very well done it there already
there's already Oscar buzz we won't jinx
it but you did an amazing job right when
you're not stalking laundromats because
we hear you like going to laundromats
right there's some great color there
yeah these people take on a role the way
you do that's true congratulations a lot
of you claim your get drunk that's great
to have you